kind of an odd voicemail today we have a
voicemail number two one nine two david
p apparently uh now pat producer pat is
the victim of sort of just general
homophobia this is something that you
know i've been critiqued for years
because I did X Y or Z because I am gay
and aside from not being true I have no
idea how that would relate to the
political criticisms that are made
anyway over the weekend the following
voicemail was received about producer
Pat Forde yo ho ho yo ho ho Patrick Ford
Patrick Ford cook golden by his mother
and his youth Patrick Ford is gayer than
a sailor yeah uh do you find that
offensive or is it just stupid no
producer has ever been treated more
unfairly than is right yeah weird I
don't know why like a pat were gay why
would that be something that hurts the
show or Jess credits his politics or
whatever I just it with every passing I
would say year but with every passing
month I find the this is a sort of
that's gay rights old it's the
equivalent of that right it's just so
lame like what are you even talking
about
yeah and that seems to have stayed it
away it seems over the past decade or so
because I think most people realize now
that's not an insult it's just part of
who you are not everybody realizes that
not everybody realizes that I've been to
some parts of the country Pat where not
everybody realizes that on the bonus
show today humans have accidentally
created a space barrier protecting
ourselves from space radiation how did
we do it
we'll talk about it on the bonus show
also a family is being slammed for
so-called reckless behavior after a
viral video caught a sea lion dragging a
girl into the water I will talk about
that and also this is not particularly
pleasing news a possible serial killer
in our city of Boston Massachusetts all
of those stories and more on the bone
show david pakman.com slash membership
is how you sign up we'll speak to you
then